>>Do you think the economy will effect the
environment in 2009 in terms of global priority?
>>DR.Adelegan: yeah, I know there will be
some impact, especially to the issue of climate
change. And we know that in Africa it's not
good to have much impact on other parts of
the world with respect to climate change.
And Africa has challenges which includes poverty,
all kinds of conflicts , problems. But with
the issue of environment having to meet with
issue of the climate, the environments that
the global economy challenge is likely to
make case in Africa to be worse than it is.
But at the same time with the discussion that
has been going on, with innovation exists
gooder in Africa, I think that with innovations
coming up Africa should be able to litigate
and to get some of these challenges but not
completely. We'll still have a lot of these
issues to handle.